what are what happens you play apartment  chicken in two chains and this is the  most expensive is this is the most  expensive his drink is $75,000 so I'm a  professional matchmaker fees could range  upward of $500,000 per movie for a wife  we have IVs that we can tailor to what  you're deficient in I'm starting to feel  a little bit of a beach way of keeping  you how do you feel I feel like you know  I'm I can play a game 21 something we  sell this for $12,000 so there's most of  your full chair has $10,000 oh these  couples are 800 a pound  sixteen thousand twenty-five thousand  three thousand dollars when I die there  means lowest oh uh Chanel stroke a Gucci  stop believin style  [Music]